Величезний тягар репутаційний, який був на міністерстві,
прибрано, і відгуки з юридичного ринку теж позитивні.
Україну все ще чи не найбільше критикують за те, що...
реформу правосуддя проведено погано.
Я не дуже вірю,
що ми стандартними способами реформування...
судовою реформою, взагалі отримаємо гарний  результат
Про Вас писали після того, як в українських СІЗО запровадили платні камери.
Є базовий рівень, який надається державою безкоштовно.
Все, що вище, - за оплату.
Ви були серед міністрів, які скаржилися на свою низьку зарплату…
Вся країна страждає, страждаємо і ми.
Пане Денисе, Ви один з небагатьох міністрів, хто перейшов з уряду Гончарука
в уряд Шмигаля. Як Ви думаєте,
за які досягнення вас залишили?
Можу лише здогадуватися.
Насправді варто таке питання задавати власне пану Шмигалю і пану Зеленському.
Мої здогадки…. Перше завдання, яке переді мною стояло -
це подолати рейдерство. Системне рейдерство ми прибрали з юридичного ринку.
Друга ключова історія може бути скоріше за все - це корупція.
Тому що величезний тягар репутаційний, який був на міністерстві,
прибрано, і відгуки з юридичного ринку теж позитивні.
Третє - напевно, що великий початок великої в’язничної реформи.
Можливо, ще реєстр засуджених. Вся база даних щодо них, автоматизація процесів,
виконання судових рішень, автоматизований арешт рахунків.
Зараз система буде викладена онлайн, можна буде дивитися.
Плюс сплата штрафів онлайн, нотаріат…
Зараз активно запустили роботу над електронним нотаріатом.
Реєстр засуджених - це коли стане можливо?
Він уже готовий. Восени закінчили розробку софту,
зараз наповнимо даними.
Ми врешті-решт в онлайн зможемо
у режимі реального часу розуміти, хто, де знаходиться, кількість,
яка кваліфікація, які злочини вчинені.
Вона допоможе нам моніторити такі строки.
Зараз  ми збираємо таку інформацію в ручному режимі.
Цифри, які ми отримуємо, вони шокуючі.
Наприклад?
Останній раз, коли ми збирали інформацію, людина перебуває
в слідчому ізоляторі 10 років. 10 років без вироку.
Матеріали ми скерували і в судову систему, і в правоохоронні органи.
Сподіваємся, буде реакція. Це разовий випадок. До десяти років рідко доходить.
Але три-чотири роки можна дуже часто зустріти в СІЗО.
Україну все ще чи не найбільше критикують
за погану реформу правосуддя.
Кожен міністр і кожен уряд це декларує
але на ділі нічого не відбувається. Ви можете відзвітувати
про якийсь конкретний поступ у реформуванні системи юстиції в Україні?
Я не дуже вірю, що ми
стандартними способами реформування,
взагалі отримаємо гарний  результат.
Весь час будь-яка влада, Ви правильно абсолютно зауважили,
декларувала судову реформу, змінювала судові органи, далеко не втекла.
Єдине, що може допомогти зробити крок вперед, це якраз цифровізація
Ми зараз плануємо активізуватися в напрямку електронного судочинства,
тому що за цим майбутнє.+++
Далі - реформа виконання кримінальних покарань.
Ми змінюємо взагалі структуру санкцій, які застосовуються судами за злочини.
Ми окремі покарання взагалі прибираємо.
Наприклад, обмеження волі.
Це, коли людина перебуває у в’язниці вночі,
а  вдень  може гуляти, працювати десь.
Повністю позбавлено санкцію покарання, воно було актуально в радянські часи,
коли ці виправні заклади займалися обробкою сільськогосподарських земель.
Вони для цього створювалися.
Зараз цього немає, і відповідно сенсу існування теж немає, а покарання залишилося.
У нас купа людей має санкції обмеження волі.
Ми прибираємо арешт як санкцію і зменшуємо мінімальні ліміти з позбавлення волі.
Ми створюємо пробаційний  нагляд.
Словом, ми замість того, щоб масово саджати людей в тюрми,
ми їх залишаємо на волі з обмеженнями: відпрацювати, знайти роботу,
пройти програми для роботи з їхніми ризиками, агресією.
Чи задоволені Ви результатами суддівської реформи, реформи прокуратури?
Реформа судів не відбувалася, не відбулася
протягом останніх кількох років. Було кілька спроб,
які поламали систему, вивели з ладу Вищу кваліфікаційну комісію судів
і призвели до шаленого дефіциту кадрів.
Не задоволений. По  прокуратурі ...
треба знову ж таки...
до кінця реформа прокуратури доведена не була.
Система розбалансована прокурорська.
Її так само треба збирати до купи, як і судову.
Відповідно з боку дивлячись на цю історію, поки не задоволений.
Україна - серед лідерів по кількості скарг до Європейського суду з прав людини.
Чому? Українська юстиція так погано працює?
Напевно, ми - велика країна, багато людей,
багато людей почувають себе ображеними, звичайно, багатий масив скарг до ЄСПЛ.
Другий аспект: у нас, порівняно з країнами Заходу, оформити скаргу в ЄСПЛ недорого,
дуже недорого. Третій аспект - і ним я пишаюся -
у нас гарно працює система безоплатної правової допомоги.
У нас існують цікаві ситуації. Є, наприклад, один довічно ув’язнений.
Він за наші кошти на нас же і скаржиться, і тягає нас по судах.
За один рік ми на нього витратили 400 000 грн.
для забезпечення безоплатної правової допомоги.
Але, безумовно, в нас є велика невідповідність
європейським стандартам і конвенціям з дуже багатьох питань.
Україна також в антилідерах за невиконанням вироків Європейського суду. Чому так?
У 90% усіх цих випадків невідповідності проблема ключова - у грошах.
Візьмемо ту саму люстрацію. Наприклад, не ми - не наша влада це створила,
прийняли закон, який не відповідає європейським стандартам.
Отримали купу рішень національних судів,
про відновлення, сплачуємо шалені кошти і як нам вийти з цієї патової ситуації,
не зовсім зрозуміло. Мова йде про мільярди.
Все одно платити доведеться за кілька років,
і рішення вкрай складне.
Рано чи пізно ми все одне закінчимо тим, що ми проведемо великий масив виплат
не грошовими коштами, а цінними паперами строком погашення кілька років.
Це єдиний  з можливих варіантів. Зараз реально живих коштів
для погашення заборгованості по ЄСПЛ немає.
Найбільше у ЗМІ про Вас писали після того, як в українських СІЗО
запровадили платні камери. Звідки взялася така ідея?
Це половина шляху до ідеї, яка була озвучена одразу після того, як я став міністром, -
створення  приватних слідчих ізоляторів. Тобто за кошти додаткові - додатковий рівень умов.
Подивитися, наскільки цей ринок, з одного боку, потенційно привабливий
для можливого інвестора з тим, щоб створювати  приватні СІЗО.
З іншого боку, додаткове джерело коштів, щоб провести ремонт у СІЗО, знову ж таки виконати
рішення ЄСПЛ щодо неналежних умов утримання. І третє - прибрати корупцію.
Люди, які потрапляють СІЗО і при цьому мають великі фінансові  ресурси, раніше сплачували хабарі.
Ви кажете, що платні камери допоможуть Україні уникнути нових скарг
до Європейського суду з прав людини з приводу поганих умов утримання.
Але чи не боїтеся Ви, що можуть з'явитися нові скарги, приміром,  щодо фінансової дискримінації?
Ні. Держава в будь-який сфері забезпечує якийсь мінімально гарантований рівень.
Наприклад, мінімальна зарплата, набір медпослуг, які ви можете отримати  безкоштовно.
Цей принцип працює і в СІЗО. Є базовий рівень, який надається державою безкоштовно.
Все, що вище, - за оплату.
Ви стверджуєте, що гроші за VIP-камери підуть на поліпшення умов утримання в СІЗО.
На скільки коштів розраховуєте?
Ми запровадили цей проект - платні камери в СЗІО - як експеримент.
Взагалі ми плануємо два роки постежити за цим.
Ми подивимося показники системи, будемо їх потихеньку змінювати. І за результатами
експерименту винесемо законопроект на розгляд Верховної Ради з тим,
щоб це запрацювало на рівні закону. Поки що це самодіяльність на ходу.
Ви заявляли про те , що хочете продавати в’язниці? Про що саме йдеться?
У нас зменшується кількість людей, які перебувають у тюрмах.
У нас є багато тюрем, які заморожені.
Є, наприклад, одна тюрма, яка знищена внаслідок бунту в Одесі.
Майже в центрі міста, величезна площа не використовується,
коштів немає і не буде на її відбудову,то чому б її не продати? Є також у Львові.
У межах міста, гарне розташування, підведені усі комунікації.
Законопроект, який дозволятиме нам це продавати і залишатиме нам 70% виручки,
вже зареєстрований у Раді. З  тим, щоб ми могли на початку осені виходити з продажем перших об’єктів.
Скільки таких в’язниць можна продати? І взагалі, чи є охочі купити?
Бажаючі є, вони завжди були. Питання лише в ціні. Для мене ключова історія із законопроектом,
щоб можна було їх продавати на відкритих електронних торгах, аукціонах.
Практично всі СІЗО в усіх облцентрах можна продати.
Проблема в тому, що коштів не буде достатньо для того, щоб побудувати нові за межами міста.
Об'єктів 10 у нас зараз потенційно є готовими для продажу
і там досить непогані кошти можна за них виручити.
Чому умови в українських в’язницях досі такі ганебні?
Кошти і корупція. Мало хто знає, але в нас є свої кар’єри, є свої ткацькі виробництва, виробництва по металу.
Але все це… половину з  того, що ці об’єкти генерують,
- воно десь розкрадається. Корупцію прибрати - прекрасне джерело надходжень
для поліпшення умов. Але ще потрібен час.
Ви заявляли, що через 2 роки у в'язницях більше не буде катувань. Ви маєте якийсь диво-план?
Нові технології. Протягом  наступних років
ми плануємо підняти зарплати  працівникам, відповідно більша конкуренціябуде,
плюс їх буде менше, ми зможемо трішки відфільтрувати персонал.
Друге - це ми плануємо максимально електронізувати все, що відбувається у в’язниці.
У тому числі застосувати ті ж самі боді-камери, щоб працівники, які ходять усередині,
щоб кожен крок записувати,  як патрульні це роблять.
Ви відвідали нещодавно Херсонську в’язницю, де перебувають хворі на туберкульоз.
Ви самі писали, що там порушені санітарні норми.
І це ж не одна така в’язниця. В українських тюрмах є ще проблема з розповсюдженням
ВІЛ-інфекції  та СНІДу.
Людина приходить здоровою, а виходить з хронічними болячками. Як з цим плануєте боротися?
По туберкульозу в нас ситуація поліпшується і загалом для тюремної системи
вона не є настільки значною. Зараз трохи більше 700 хворих на туберкульоз.
І ця цифра постійно упродовж останніх років зменшується. У нас гірше з ВІЛ.
Більше 3500 хворих, значно більше, ніж на туберкульоз.
Ще гірше з гепатитом вірусним.  Кожен третій хворий на вірусний гепатит В.
І це проблема, проблема суспільства загалом.
Поки ми не вилікуємо всю ситуацію по країні,
вона буде в більш концентрованому вигляді відображена в тюрмах.
У провадженні Мінюсту заходиться 5 позовів України проти РФ, які вже передали міжнародним судам.
Наскільки перспективними ви їх вважаєте?
З величезною долею вірогідності ми їх виграємо. Проблема в тому, що
наша ж кінцева мета - це не просто виграти 5-7 судів,
а врешті повернути  наші території, людей і отримати компенсації. Це складніше. Ми зараз працюємо
над стратегією цієї війни разом з українськими і провідними
іноземними юристами і досить скоро перейдемо до більш комплексних  і ефективних заходівщодо боротьби з РФ.
Але загальна проблема - це пошук активів, які можна стягнути.
У нас можуть бути виграні суди на мільярди, вже є виграні. Але активів, які можна відібрати у росіян
за кордоном, майже немає. А всередині  РФ нам жодної копійки не заплатять...
То Україна не отримає компенсації за тимчасово втрачені території в Криму і в Донбасі?
Отримає, але коли це відбудеться і в якому обсязі - це велике питання.
Ви були серед міністрів, які скаржилися на свою низьку зарплату…
І зараз скаржуся.
Чому знову скаржитеся?
Незадоволений, як і будь-яка людина, тому що зарплата низька.
Але зараз окремий період, коли зарплата у всіх чиновників обмежена 10 мінімальними зарплатами.
Вся країна страждає, страждаємо і ми.
Можете назвати суму?
37 000 грн.
Тоді яка у вас мотивація працювати?
Будь-яка, окрім грошової. Немає ніякої грошової. У зв’язку з цим отримую безліч скарг від родини,
від батьків, і від себе теж, тому що думаю, навіщо воно того варте.
Але для роботи існує низка інших аспектів, чому людина обирає ту чи іншу роботу. В мене так само.
І досвід новий, нові знання, навички…
Це теж відіграє свою роль. Поки що доводиться витрачати зі своїх старих накопичень.
Ваш слоган на Фейсбук-сторінці - "Ні смотрящім!" Над Вами "смотрящіх" немає?
Немає.
Ви точно впевнені?
Ну, Бог, президент та прем’єр, тоді так.
Дуже дякую!
Вам дякую.